sorry the long-awaited star wars episode
9 trailer has dropped in we're here to
break it down for you our very first
trailer for the rise of Skywalker opens
with Rey alone on a desert planet
armed with the only lightsaber looking a
lot like Padme now that you mention it
it's definitely Luke's lightsaber from
the previous film which some fans had
speculated may have been destroyed well
apparently not is this Jack ooh are we
back on jakku again it could be another
desert planet maybe Tatooine kind of
hard to tell them apart really if you've
seen one you see them all we hear Luke's
encouraging words and voiceover telling
ray that a thousand generations of Jedi
knowledge have been passed to her he's
passed on all we know a thousand
generations live in you now and then it
certainly seems like kylo Ren ship comes
in for an attack can't be sure we just
see some black gloves but come on who
else is it gonna be grand moff tarkin
he's dead
then it's off to a city on a cloud
planet or maybe a snow planet shots of
kylo Ren in battle and repairing his old
helmet remember the one he smashed in
the last Jedi after Snoke made fun of
him he can be very sensitive guys
puffin and Threepio are on this
adventure together and we can see that
they're also on a desert planet which
will eventually host some kind of major
battle there's one quick shot a
fan-favorite bb-8 in his new droid pal
who has apparently named do he has a
funnel for a head up next we're inside
the Millennium Falcon already going at
Lightspeed and guess who's at the
controls that's right Billy Dee Williams
reprising his classic role as Lando
Calrissian from the original trilogy
he's even wearing that recognizable
yellow and blue shirt we saw him wearing
in solo and it still fits
this guy's smooth he's been reunited
with copilot Chewbacca and maybe a
bottle of colt 45 as well there are two
rules to remember if you want to have a
good time rule number one never run out
of colt 45
rule number two never forget rule number
one general Leia hugs rey and a scene
that's sure to get emotional in the
finished film she's holding the metal
that Han and Luke both received at the
end of a new hope cue the waterworks
notably at this point we hear dear
departed Luke and voice over promising
we'll always be with you and no one's
ever really gone certainly seems to be a
tip-off that Rey will be advised by Luke
and possibly even some other Jedi in
this new adventure
very likely enforced ghost form we know
Anakin obi-wan and qui-gon also have
this ability definitely some potential
cameos there or it could just be a nice
nod to the late Carrie Fisher as she'll
always be with us in spirit it's also
the first of several indications that
some additional original trilogy friends
will be stopping by for this final
adventure the next clue is the big title
the rise of Skywalker wait rise all the
Skywalker's are dead right no what are
you up to movie this is sure to set off
months of fan speculation it could of
course mean that kylo was wrong or lying
about Rey's background in the last Jedi
and that she really
is a secret Skywalker after all or it
could mean that Luke is going to make
his glorious return and that he just
disappeared at the end of the last Jedi
rather than dying or it could just refer
to the rise of the Skywalker legend
which rallies or inspires the galaxy to
resist the first order perhaps Skywalker
itself becomes a blanket term for the
resistance or maybe Han and Leia had
another kid named Pete Skywalker and we
just haven't met him yet any of these
are possible but then the final shocker
is still to come as the trailer ends we
see our heroes overlooking what appears
to be the ruins of the second Death Star
possibly indicating they're on Endor or
one of its moons on the soundtrack we
can clearly hear the iconic laugh of a
certain evil Emperor Palpatine and if
anyone wasn't convinced that's really
him
actor Ann McDermid showed up at Star
Wars Celebration in person after the
trailer played well he simply be a synth
ghost or as Palpatine finally found a
way to truly cheat death as he's always
promised young Anakin Skywalker he would
[Music]
wait is Anakin Skywalker who's rising I
need to lie down
well that's what we were able to discern
from the two minutes of footage but
we're not perfect you may have seen
something we didn't spot and if you did
hit us up in the comments and tell us
about it
or just let us know how you're gonna
make it through the next seven months
until this movie opens breathing
exercises some kind of meditation I need
help
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]